okay so Spider-Man across the spider
verse has just seen its second trailer
drop online and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the new
look all the Easter eggs in it and also
giving our thoughts and theories on
what's going on tatted as being miles
versus every Spider-Man the upcoming
film is the first in a two-part
storyline send it around the events that
are kick-start in this film now the
first spider-verse movie all had the
heroes returning home due to them
glitching at miles's Universe however we
saw Spider-Man 2099 in the post-credits
scene and he brought with him a new
device that stabilized one's multiversal
travel this can be seen on everyone's
wrist and I'm guessing that Miles might
weaponize these at some point to stop
the Spider-Man chasing after him 2099
seems like he's actually gonna be an
antagonist in this movie and it's a far
cry from how he's depicted in the comics
it's likely because of him that all of
the Spider-Man have been pulled together
however it's very much his way or the
highway now in case you don't know his
real name is Miguel O'Hara and he's half
Irish and half Mexican coming from the
futuristic city Nueva York the character
made his way up the ranks of the
alchemax corporation which controlled
most of the city you might recognize
this from the first film as being what
Kingpin used to create the multiversal
portal and they're probably going to be
a big threat in every Universe working
as a scientist for them he was pressured
into running an experiment on himself
which would imprint genetic codes onto
humans his DNA was spliced with that of
his spiders and it gives him the powers
that we see him having here we don't
really find out his full plan in the
teaser but Judah miles and Gwen even
possibly going against them I think I
have a fair idea it is possible that
they need miles's father to die and in
this happening it'll create this version
of Spider-Man he does give it on to Tom
Holland's version in the teaser and
talks about how he already messed up
everything so I'm guessing that this was
because he wanted to save the villains
that caused a lot of problems in that
film and Miles wanting to save his
father could very much be a repeat of
that in Saving someone you alter the
course of history create a Nexus event
and then this spreads often fractures
into other timelines so I'm guessing
that this is what what's at stake here
and we've seen from the other trailers
that he's very much focused on his
daughter raila he wants to save her no
matter the cost and thus he's willing to
put this in danger to make sure that she
stays alive now his daughter's name is
actually another greater universe and
Riley was Aunt May's maiden name which
was adopted by Ben Reilly Ben Reilly was
a clone of Peter Parker and he took her
maiden name along with his uncle's first
name Riley is going to be popping up in
the movie too and we'll talk later on
about how we see him in the trailer
either way 2099 is clearly the leader of
all the other Spider-Man and I'm going
to be trying to break down all the ones
that pop up in this new look just pray
for me now we do know from the plot
synopsis that these have been charged
with guarding the very existence of the
Multiverse and I think that they bring a
lot with them for this film anyway that
takes us into the trailer itself so
smash the Thumbs Up Button before we get
into it please subscribe and yeah let's
go baby
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what okay miles
he's lying to you now that first trailer
opened with Miles sat on his roof which
is where he was joined by his mother she
was talking about how the boy that she
knew is no longer there and in this new
look they sort of build upon that they
show that though miles enjoys being
Spider-Man he clearly finds it difficult
juggling the two sides of his life
they're all about trying to have a
normal life but they also have to
balance that alongside being Spider-Man
they also have to protect the ones
closest to them and in order to do this
they have to stay distant from the
people they love every spider person has
watched someone they loved are in front
of them and thus cutting people off is
the easiest way to go about it now the
trailer begins with Miles swinging
outside of Visions Academy which was the
school lady got a scholarship to in the
first movie on the ground we catch a big
shout out to me and we can see a bus
going by that says this spoiler guessing
that this is actually just giving away a
big plot point in the movie where the
bus is going so they might have covered
it up however it might also be a nod to
the Marvel character spoiler who has
enhanced strength and durability and can
also knock a trailer breakdown out in
about two minutes now there's also a red
X van beside this which is obviously
playing on FedEx this is showing how the
world differentiates from ours we see
him rushing through the school Corridor
and you might notice that he's looking
slightly older than he was the last time
he then swings to New York and we can
catch several Puerto Rico Flags miles is
half Puerto Rican as well and it's nice
just getting these nods in the
environment he saves a taxi from
crushing some people and this is sort of
riffing on when Amazing Spider-Man
stopped it from happening in his movies
however doing all this stuff on top of
everything else has kind of cut into his
social life and we see him arriving at
what I think is a birthday party late
might not be because it looks like
everyone's there it might be a block
party I don't know and I'm sure someone
right now in the comments is yelling at
me so if that's you thanks further
correction it doesn't seem that bothered
because he's got more stuff on his mind
which is definitely getting to his
parents at this point we cut to the spot
and though he's been downplayed in a lot
of marketing for the movie it has been
said that he's gonna be a big villain
that spans both films though the first
movie dealt with Kingpin we need a
multiversal threat and it has been
confirmed that he's going to be a
villain behind this and the third film
now in the comics he was called Jonathan
own and he was a highly decorated
graduate of MIT that was even roommates
with Quentin Beck a divorced dad he
started working for the Kingpin and he
was tasked with discovering how the
clock's Powers worked in case you don't
know the cloak can basically create
portals within himself and the Kingpin
wanted to duplicate this power for his
own personal gains due to his origin
story he may be linked in with the first
film and we might learn potentially that
he helped Kingpin build the collider
either way a big Theory time for that
but we do know that Owen succeeded in
his research after creating a portal one
night however what he didn't plan on
happening was that he'd be sucked into
it and this is where he entered the
cloak stock Dimension here he starred a
master the realm and he looked about at
the other portals for the place that he
just come from after walking through the
landscape he managed to return home but
he discovered that the portals had
attached themselves to him turned out
that when he was in the dark I mentioned
the portals had attached themselves to
his skin like leeches and they basically
made him into a walking wormhole in the
comics he is pretty much a joke
character that's not really the big bad
um but which they are kind of bringing
across in this new look however he does
possess Extremely Dangerous Powers and
this could be Unleashed on the
Multiverse which causes lots of problems
in it from an animation point of view
there's lots of fun things I can do with
him and just watching that that bread
fall out of his stomach it really shows
you how goofy he is however yeah like I
said very dangerous so yeah keep an eye
off him because the guy is gonna cause
some trouble we see that Miles lifts his
mask up to Eid and this is also
something that Spider-Man does
throughout the Saga you know you've seen
it before get away from her a miles
tackling this spot also causes more
trouble in his life as we see that he's
late to his parents meeting we call it
parents evening in the UK don't know
what they call it in America but if
you've been on one of the wrong side of
these you know you can get in a lot of
trouble now you might notice that Miles
has got a BLM badge on his bag and to
make matters worse he's not learned
Spanish he's not he's failing it and his
mother is not very happy he's clearly
siding with his dad and this is paid off
later on when he's also very focused on
saving his life his spot interrupts once
more and he has to leave the meeting
early again to go off and save the world
[Music]
win so wait a minute there's an elite
crew with all the best spider people in
it who's the new guy this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's it I gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Dr
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99
come on go easy on the kid he had a
terrible teacher Peter miles you have a
baby
I'll take it from here at this point we
once more visit miles room which has
been in every single trailer I've broken
it down lots of times but in case you
haven't seen those videos which I know
you haven't because you don't like this
channel then we're gonna be going
through it again so miles is actually
wearing a basketball jersey with a
number 42 on it and 42 was a number that
constantly appeared in the first movie
it brings a lot with it as not only is
this the meaning of everything but it's
also the number that Jackie Robinson
wore Jackie was the first black athlete
to play Major League Baseball and the
first movie had this number throughout
this as a nod to him by his head we can
also catch the cover of Amazing Fantasy
15 which was the first appearance of
your boy's Spider-Man now Gwen calls out
to him now we can see that she's wearing
a pink jacket whereas in the first look
she wasn't you can also catch that he's
pinned up some bus tickets on the wall
and this was the one that he wrote in
the first film with Peter B I Gwen
looking down through a hexagonal portal
has a very important meaning with it as
these are what the heroes travel through
throughout this trailer hexagonal
puddles have popped up throughout a lot
of the MCU and primarily they're used as
jump points in space here though they'll
be used to go through the Multiverse and
it'll allow us to see lots of different
realities and also characters you might
also notice that every Spider-Man and
woman has a device on their wrist and
this will allow them to travel through
the portals using them more as tracks to
get to predetermined worlds this will
stop them from just shooting across the
Multiverse and it's a similar device to
what Tony developed in Avengers end game
where they're acting like a GPS and from
this point we catch israe's version of
Spider-Woman and he's gonna be a big
character in the movie too she looks
down at the bump almost seeming
depressed with we've all been there
don't tell the wife and there but she's
clearly thinking I have this great power
and now this great responsibility
in case you don't know Spider-Woman real
name Jessica Drew she's a massive
character in the Spider-Man universe and
she's featured in a number of major
stories like secret Invasion and more
introduced in 1978 she was great because
Stanley was worried that another comic
book company would try and make their
own character that would be called
Spider-Woman now this may not be her as
it does look slightly different and we
do see later on that there's a comic
book accurate Spider-Woman either way
though Drew was originally only meant to
be in a Marvel's Spotlight but she
became so popular that they decided to
use her in more given a series with her
Marv Wolfman went over her backstory and
he changed things up from what was
originally established Spider-Woman was
meant to be a spider that transformed
into a woman but this was pretty goofy
so they retconned it so that these were
just memories implanted by Hydra he has
all the typical spider powers that you'd
expect but she also brings with her
energy blasts too the one we see here
has a motorbike as well and though she
can shoot webs out of her hands I might
have done this because she's not gonna
be swinging now when she was shown last
time everyone kicked off but it's
important to bear in mind that there
have been several redos of her her
current origin story is that her mother
was hit by a radiation being when she
was pregnant and this contained multiple
spider genes I gave her her powers
although she's become one of the more
prominent characters in the Marvel
Universe she did actually see a decline
when she was first launched she was
killed off originally in her 50th issue
but Bendis brought her back for his new
Avengers since then the character's gone
on to be a big player and though we
don't get a classic design in Essa we do
see it in the trailer itself now the
next Spider-Man that we see is spider
Punk and we know that he'll be Voice by
Daniel caluya first debuting back an
Amazing Spider-Man 10 from 2015 he was
originally riffing on spider UK the
character hails from Earth 138 and we
discovered in that that he was a
homeless teenager named Herbert Brown he
was transformed due to some Oscorp toxic
waste and he became the spider Punk that
we see here known as a rocker he carries
a guitar with him everywhere and easy
even use this to beat up Norman Osborne
the spider-verse comic storyline he was
brought in by superior Spider-Man and
he's probably gonna be a big addition to
the film now that we get his classic
look here we can also see a Spider-Man
later on holding a guitar and I think
this might be a variation of the
character we know from the funkos that
this will be the main one though but
yeah that's just a theory time oh for
what I noticed in the trailer now from
this we jump across to another
Spider-Man and see Spider-Man India
popping up too pavita parakbar which
apologies I've pronounced that wrong his
family ditched life in their Village to
move to Mumbai after he gained a
scholarship at one of the schools this
is similar to miles in the first movie
and the kids there made fun of him
because of his poorer upbringing he
encountered an ancient Yogi who gave him
spider powers but he initially just used
them for his own gain his defining
moment happened when he ignored someone
being attacked by muggers and he
returned to the scene later to find that
his uncle had been killed he jumped in
to stop them and had Spider-Man in the
intervene then this never would have
happened from this point onwards he does
decided to use his abilities for GERD
and it's awesome seeing him popping up
in the trailers Indian Cinemas been on
fire the last couple of years there's
been so many good movies released that
it's nice seeing them also getting their
own version of Spider-Man on the big
screen now from here we go to the lobby
which I'm guessing is an access point
and it's something that we saw in the
first trailer I know that seems like
it's a more packed shot but it's pretty
much just in line with what we get here
with them all piled on top of each other
now we start off with the PS4 one and
right next to him is the bulletproof
suit which also pops up as a skin in
that game but this may also be the one
from the what if storyline in which
Peter stayed with the Venom symbiote now
to the left of that we have a fatter
armored Spider-Man and to the left of
him is a character wearing the armor
suit again from the PS4 game and I'm
pretty sure that all three of these
popped up in the spider cave during the
first film the new games also releasing
later on this year and it will be
building off the back of the first one
which I think I've now bought three
times see you chump in that Peter was in
the midst of of his career and the game
started off with him taking down the
Kingpin he also helped his Aunt May out
at Beast who was running it alongside
her partner Martin Lee now he was
revealed to be Mr negative who basically
hated Norman Osborne and always hit the
thumbs down button negative attempted to
stop Norman Osborne's re-election as
mayor and he attacked an event which
miles father was killed at later on
Miles was bitten by genetically
engineered spider and the Peter of that
Universe ended up becoming his mentor
and we kind of get the feeling in this
moment too with him chatting along and
just looking after that little spider
kid at the left of them we can also
catch Spider-Woman and then the rubber
suit which was used to fight Electro
alongside this is the golden and red one
that was used in Civil War and this is
what Tony gave Peter after he joined the
pro-registration ACT we then catch a
sort of cyberpunk Spider Woman and this
is Lady spider from Earth 803 Mabel
Riley actually built the harness in the
arms herself and she joined the
Multiverse spider Army at one point in
the comics she's on a laptop with the
largest Spiderman and then and to the
left of them we can catch spider cop
this is someone who appeared in the
comics and in those he was an NYPD
veteran that was recruited to help out
the spider-verse storyline just to the
top left we can also catch a Spider-Man
with no sleeves and gloves on and this
is a character that also pops up on top
of the train I actually think that this
is the manga verse Peter who is the last
ninja of the spider Clan is Sensei Ben
was killed by Venom and hopefully we see
him busting out some cool things in the
film now the train brings a lot with it
too and alongside that classic looking
Spider Woman we can also catch a
Cyborg's Spider-Woman we have the lady
one again and what also looks like a
sexy Santa Helper just don't tell a wife
there's also one wearing gray sweater
and again this could be roughing on the
PS4 game as you pull further out we can
catch werewolf Spider-Man and also lots
of other different spider women you can
also see the bombastic Bag Man or rather
the amazing batman when Spider-Man was
separated from the Symbiote in the
Baxter building he ended up having to
wear this and to cover his face he put a
bag over his head this is being used in
a number of different games as a bonus
skin and even have a sort of 60s pop art
style animation when the character walks
along we also have what may or may not
be Spider-Man Unlimited from the mid 90s
series as his costume seems to have been
brought across into lots of the
background characters now at this point
Miguel drops in and you might also
notice that he's fighting a certain
character this is actually the vulture
and you might remember that he appeared
for a split second in the last teaser
he's been specifically designed to look
like a Renaissance painting he carries
an Italian accent the character will be
voiced by John matakon the guy is
actually Italian so he'll not be doing
his best let's go to show how Italian he
is and I'm guessing that this is a cool
action scene to introduce 2099 he you
see him toss one of the wrist devices to
Gwen and also the Spider-Man walking
along looking at theirs this is why I'm
taking at least I needed to travel the
Multiverse and I'm guessing that miles
will strip the characters of these to
stop them from chasing him down now it's
clear that miles wants to join him and
the rest of the group but Miguel shuts
this down and mentions Doctor Strange he
talks about the Spider-Man from Earth
One 999 whatever it is it should be 616
but then the comics is that so it's a
lot very confusing and it's clear that
he doesn't think miles is gonna be a
good asset and the back of this shot you
might also notice that there's a
Spider-Man who seems to be being held
midair now this might be a prisoner and
Theory time but perhaps this is an axis
being that they need in order to access
the other realities and this could be
what's going on here big reach on that
but yeah just weird seeing him at the
back now the tension's broken up by PW
Parker who will be returning and we know
from what he's wearing and what happens
that him and MJ did get back together
concept art was leaked early on and this
shot made a Parker who makes a big
impression as she enters the scene she's
inherited her father's spider powers and
though Miguel's cringing she thought
this was a really cool addition to the
teaser it's always good seeing my guy
back and even though he shows up late in
the trailer like his rent payment he's
probably gonna end up being one of the
big players in the movie PW Parker was
of course miles mentor and though he
seems to be on 2099 side I can't see him
switching once the movie gets further
into things
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my own let me guess
he died
now from this point we cut to Miles
running through the city and also get a
shot of Gwen in the first film we
learned that in her universe that it was
Peter who died and we see this playing
out here interestingly they do sort of
change things up and in that original
flashback he had lizard scales whereas
here he looks normal because of that we
all thought that he was the lizard uh
but here they seem to have changed it up
and just made him a normal guy and
because he died that means her father
didn't and we know that we're going to
be meeting Captain Stacy in this movie
Boys by Shea Wiggum he died in the 616
but he's gonna be returning here making
me think that we're going to be seeing a
lot more of this world now this idea of
sacrifice is also brought across the
miles and he's given a choice of saving
one person or saving the Multiverse
because of the way that his father shot
I'm guessing that this is going to be
him and it's gonna weigh heavily on
miles's shoulders 2099 clearly doesn't
want him to be able to go back and do
this and this is why I think they're
trying to hold miles in place and they
do kind of mislead Us in the trailer a
bit and you can tell that where is
Father Falls is a different world to the
world that we see next this looks more
like the Spider-Man India universe and
I'm guessing that they've just stitched
these two shots together and from this
point we get spider bite who we also
know will be appearing in the film as
well though she looks different from the
comics this has been confirmed by the
funkos and in case you don't know she
comes from a world that's basically
Ready Player one this is the universe
where most people live in cyberspace and
they use the avatars to interact with
others spider bite stops cyber crime and
she does this for the community so
everyone can have a good game you see
her switching about from one place to
the other she's typing on a computer and
therefore I'm guessing it here might not
be though but yeah let me know below now
from here we get a moment in which 2099
is cut with the spot and this makes me
think that he might actually be
possessing the character we catch him in
the dark dimension with several portals
around him and though this isn't part of
his skill set it might be a place where
he can reach out to other realities
miles seems shocked almost like he
realizes this is the case and this could
potentially be him stopping Miguel from
being taken over by the character now
either way he asks to be sent home and
we can also see behind Miguel that is
help us there from the first movie he
then rushes through Mumbai and goes to
save Gwen before we could to PW Parker
who's looking very remorseful I'm
guessing that he's also realized that
Mars's father has to die and
unfortunately it's a sacrifice that all
the characters have to go through though
miles lost his uncle Aaron in the first
movie they clearly demand more blood and
this is going to be a very
heart-wrenching story he races across
the Multiverse and from this point we
get several action shots in which the
characters chase him nice little moment
amongst this and you might notice that
melee Parker also has her own Spider-Man
mask might belong to Peter but yeah
either way he's using it to cover her
head as they ride on top of the train at
this point we get a moment that riffs on
the first film and we can see miles
charging up likely before he
electrocutes 2099 and from here Miguel
puts out a warning to the rest of the
Multiverse and He commands all the other
spider people to come and get miles
during this we catch the Scarlet Spider
and as I mentioned before this is Ben
Reilly and after novel a character he
has been kind of ostracized but he
originates from the clone saga that
dominated the 90s during that time
Publishers were replacing their main
Heroes with their divisions and just in
the same way that Batman was replaced by
John Paul Valley Peter Parker was pushed
out too created by the Jackal using
Peter's DNA it was thought that the
Clone died alongside his creator all the
way back in the 70s however it turned
out that he survived this and realizing
that he was a clone he decided to live
in Exile using his uncle's first name
and Aunt May's maiden name he was
inspired to become his own person that
was sort of like a Drifter moving from
town to town helping people his spider
Sensei did several police investigations
zani fell in love with a woman called
Janine who too was on the Run being
racked with girl she ended her own life
and Ben became a janitor at Portland
high school he saved a woman from some
home Invaders and was once more inspired
to use his great powers to to take on
great responsibilities eventually he
went back to New York and he confronted
Peter who helped him get through some of
his bad times he worked alongside
Spider-Man as the Scarlet Spider and
eventually he became the main one after
Peter stepped back he seemed to discover
that he was the Clone and not Ben and at
this point it almost drove him insane
this was of course all eventually
revealed to be untrue and Peter took the
role back as the main one in the
universe boys loved his costume design
though and the animation style of the
use here really hearkens back to how it
was in the 90s that was far more gritty
and grimy and yeah it's great seeing how
good the suit looks here now from here
we cut back to all the Spider-Man and
can see the Ultimate Spider-Man one and
also the PS4 one it will get a message
like Order 66 and this tells them to go
after Miles Morales from here they all
do the pointing meme very good and we
can even catch one hanging from the
ceiling by his fingertips like Andrew
Garfield didn't know a home just nice
seeing this meme referenced again I I
love it and I think there's also a
samurai Spider-Man at the back judging
by the logo on the back of this one I
think this also might be the 90s
animated version but let me know below
if it's not and if you spot any others
here either way it all leads to a big
chase that ends in a therapist's office
and I love how they have a Rorschach
test on the wall that looks exactly like
a spider really nice bit of attention to
detail here and they burst through the
wall making me say oh yeah amongst these
the one that stands out the most is the
horse Spider-Man which we can see at the
front wearing the red mask the first
film obviously introduced Peter Porker
AKA spider pig and it's nice that his
powers extend to other animals anyway
that concludes the trailer what a
brilliant time it was not to make a
breakdown for that was the worst time of
my life but yeah as for a first look
this looks absolutely brilliant I'm sure
you can tell that I'm really really
excited and it feels like the next
couple of months are gonna be really big
when it comes to comic book movies and
shows we of course have secret Invasion
Blue Beetle this The Flash and also
Guardians of the Galaxy the week has
been full lower trailers and every one
of them has done a fantastic job of
getting me on board with what's coming
the first movie was one of my favorite
Spider-Man films ever it looks like
they're upping the ante on every level
here to bring us what's likely gonna be
another classic I really can't wait and
I hope you've enjoyed our breakdown on
the new look been exhausting getting
this out huge announce to my editor
Steven who's piled through this with me
and yeah hopefully I'll see you after
the release where we can talk about the
movie in depth anyway huge thank you for
checking out the video and make sure you
leave comments Below on what you want to
see in the film and if you're excited or
not we are in a competition right now
giving away the Superman 4K box set of
three subscribers on the 15th of April
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the teaser who picked the
comments at random on the 15th and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of one of
the other trailers which will be linked
on the screen right now lots of things
to talk about so definitely head over
there right after this to one of them
you've got the blue beatler secret
Invasion I'll leave the choice up to you
I'll see you over there take care peace